alors ce matin encore
j'étais dans une salle donc juste à côté
d'ici dont le bâtiment h pour ceux qui
connaissent et j'enseignais la
macroéconomie à des étudiants de
première année qui se reconnaît juste là
ça fait maintenant quatre ans que
j'enseigne donc l'économie la finance
que ça soit ici même ou à la sorbonne et
depuis quatre ans en fait à chaque fois
qu à chaque fois que fait un court mais
chaque année il ya toujours un étudiant
qui est un moment ou un autre
lève la main vient me voir ou m'envoie
un email pour me poser cette même
question fatidique mais en fait monsieur
voilà on m'appelle monsieur parfois même
mais en fait monsieur tout ce qu'on voit
là en cours les hypothèses les modèles
les théories mais ça marche pas du tout
en réalité si et là c'est un peu le
drame il ya une technique classique que
j'ai un petit peu utilisé au début la
technique de l' esquive vous répondez
énorme et les modèles c'est un peu
compliqué vous verrez ça plus tard
bon bref aujourd'hui ce qu'on va essayer
de faire en 12 minutes
on va essayer de métier de vous montrer
justement à quoi sert l'économie et de
vous montrer qu'il ya un changement qui
est en train de se passer dans le monde
économique avec un passage d'une
économie très théorique et mathématiques
à une économie davantage basé sur les
données et pour ça il me faudrait ça
alors je vais si vous avez vous
l'impression que l'économie est quand
même pas mal déconnecté de la réalité
vous inquiétez pas vous n'êtes pas non
plus les seuls vous ai mis deux
citations
au tableau que j'ai commenté rapidement
une citation donc de l'antienne est une
de krugman
si vous connaissez pas ces noms c'est
des prix nobel d'économie sont pas trop
débile donc ce qu'il raconte prenez le
rend compte
on voit qu'à une même chose qui revient
ici une critique de l'économie purement
mathématique purement théorique avec
justement le fait qu'en économie il ya
eu en tout cas après la seconde guerre
mondiale le fait que le côté l'élégance
théorique et pris le dessus sur la
recherche de la vérité
petit problème on a quand même 30 ans
d'écart entre ces deux critiques
les critiques se ressemblent beaucoup et
on va essayer de voir est ce que dans
trente ans que dans quinze ans ces
critiques reviendrons alors quelques
quelques notes d'espoir faut savoir que
dans le monde académique
il ya déjà une chose qui est en train de
changer si vous prenez donc moi aussi je
suis chercheur un peu comme dennis moi
aussi j'adore mon job mais aussi on
prend pour quelqu'un de bizarre comme
simon mais bref on fait de la recherche
il faut savoir qu'un chercheur lorsqu'il
fait de la recherche il fait tout mon 3
il utilise une méthodologie parmi trois
principales il ya des chercheurs qui
sont davantage basées sur des modèles
mathématiques théorique
vous faites des équations vous trouver
un équilibre c'est ce qu'on appelle la
recherche théorique
vous avez la recherche empirique la
recherche empirique vous aller collecter
des données ou vous baser sur des
données existantes vous essayer de
montrer des relations entre des
variables avec un peu d'économétrie un
petit attapeu trucs comme ça dernière
option vous mettez des gendres de
laboratoire vous regardez comment ils
réagissent et à partir de ça vous
essayez de soit confirmée des théories
soit justement développer des nouvelles
ce qu'on voit donc depuis dans ce
tableau là donc c'est une étude
académique pour ceux que ça intéresse
d'aller creuser un peu vous avez
l'évolution entre 83 et 2013 du type de
recherche
et on voit très bien actuellement et
même si on s'en rend pas forcément bien
content on a une très forte diminution
de nombre de recherches théoriques avec
réellement une économie qui devient d'un
point de vue académique davantage
connecté à la réalité
grosse montée des recherches empiriques
et expérimentale mais c'est quoi
justement ces recherches empiriques et
pourquoi dans un teddy que cela en quoi
on va parler d'économie je vais vous
présenter rapidement trois projets qui
réellement montre l'intérêt du big data
en économie et en quoi même l'économie
ça peut presque être un peu cool un
projet sur ebay un superbe crochet de m6
qui est ce que je fais un petit peu dans
ma thèse donc je suis et doctorat à la
sorbonne en finance que je fais un petit
peu dans la thèse avec twitter alors
commençons par ebay vous avez une
hypothèse centrale en microéconomie pour
tout ce que l'on fait on suppose la
présence d'un homo economicus donc
l'homo economicus c'est quelqu'un qui
est rationnel pour le dire autrement
c'est une machine de guerre qui prend
toujours les bonnes décisions qui va
toujours acheter le bon produit le moins
cher
si vous vous souvenez un peu des cours
d'économie il maximise son bien-être
sous contrainte
sauf que cette hypothèse de base de
l'ensemble des modèles est ce qu'elle
est vrai est ce que vous êtes des
machines de guerre
moi je le suis pas malheureusement vous
l'êtes pas non plus et il ya des
chercheurs qui le prouve maintenant
prouver la rationalité c'est en fait
assez compliquées récemment dans une
étude de 2015 quatre chercheurs
américains ont justement fait un
partenariat avec ebay pour tester la
rationalité
comment est ce qu'ils ont fait donc ils
ont extrait 355 millions d'offres de
transactions réalisées sur ebay et se
sont intéressés justement à étudier le
comportement des acheteurs et le
comportement des vendeurs
un exemple que j'aime bien donc qui est
un petit peu adaptée mais l'idée est là
supposons noël arrive vous avez envie
d'acheter une peluche pikachu pour votre
neveu vous allez donc sur ebay vous
tapez peluche pikachu pas cher vous
arrivez sur ces trois offres
ces trois offres même vendeur
même produit forcément vous voyez 3
offre une première offre le la peluche
coûte 20 euros les frais de port sont
gratuits
une deuxième offre 5 euros avec 15 euros
frais de port une troisième offre 16
euros avec 3 euros 70 de frais de port
modèle classique d'économie rationalité
des agents les agents vont choisir la
plus chassée euros avec 3 euros 70 de
frais de port pour quoi ça minimise
votre coût total
sauf qu'en réalité il se passe quoi en
réalité au contraire les agents ne sont
pas rationnels dans le sens où ils
survalorise la livraison gratuite ou à l
inverse il n'arrive pas à prendre en
compte le fait que des frais de porcs
élevés implique un prix total élevé cet
exemple justement de test de la
rationalité montre forcément que
certains modèles économiques sont basées
sur des hypothèses qui sont relativement
fragile et montre aussi l' avantage du
big data
tout ce que ça peut apporter au niveau
des tests des théories économiques et
les théories économiques qu'on peut
développer par dessus pensez-y
si jamais vous revendez vos vieux
cadeaux sur noël enfin sur lunel sur le
bon coin après noël
pensez simplement à ça si vous voulez
maximiser votre profil livraison
gratuite ou fred pour élever un autre
exemple cas pas grand chose à voir mais
justement sur l'intérêt du big data en
économie c'est un exemple d'une haïti
alors faut savoir que en économie on a
du mal à prévoir le présent prévoir le
présent ça paraît un peu un peu
antinomique mais une variable macro
économique lorsqu'elle est publié les
publier avec du retard
par exemple aujourd'hui on a eu une
inflation qui a été publié pour la
france pour le mois d'octobre
ça veut dire que on a entre 12 et 43
jours de retard sur le chiffre
d'inflation
vous êtes chercheur en économie vous
avez envie de vous dire
l'inflation mensuelle il ya un retard en
plus ça coûte cher faut payer des gens
pour collecter les données faut payer
des gens pour analyser les données
retard plus variables mensuels
comment est ce que vous faites pour cela
vous créer des robots des algorithmes
qui chaque jour vont aller extraire les
informations sur l'ensemble des sites
internet de vente de biens et de
services grâce à ça vous pouvez faire
deux choses premièrement donc ça s'est
extrait du bilan ce project est
justement le
roger dumas qui vous pouvez avoir une
inflation jour par jour quasiment
gratuitement
pourquoi quasiment gratuitement vous
devez juste payer les serveurs ça coûte
un petit peu d'argent et par rapport au
coût de la collecte d'informations et
aux coudes analyses de la part de
l'insee ou de tout institut stats c'est
bien inférieur
on voit d'ailleurs sur ce graphique donc
vous avez ample l'inflation officielle
et vous avez en rouge l'inflation
calculée à partir des données internet
vous voyez que les deux inflation sont
très corrélé donc ici le big data utile
à la fois pour avoir les données avant
et réduire la fréquence mais en plus de
ça il ya quand même une idée derrière le
big dada c'est d'essayer de rapprocher
de la réalité ou d'essayer de montrer
une nouvelle vérité
un des deux auteurs de ce papier est
argentin et il s'est dit finalement en
argentine le gouvernement mois m'annonce
que l'inflation et 10% par an quand moi
je vais en argentine que je demande à ma
famille et je regarde l'évolution des
prix j'ai l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup
plus comment montrer que le gouvernement
argentin mais pour ça il a lancé c'est
même robot sauf qui les a lancés sur
l'ensemble des sites internet argentin
de vente de biens et services
ce qu'il a réussi à montrer donc ça a
été une publication d'un top journal
académique et le fmi s'est emparé de ce
cas suit en partie à la suite de ça ils
ont réussi à montrer que par exemple en
2013 l'argentine le chiffre officiel
était de 10 % alors qu'en réalité
l'inflation était de 25%
voyez ici un cac assez simple finalement
on se dit on fait des robots on a des
données sur internet on analyse
permettant justement de rapprocher
l'économie de la réalité et de faire que
l'économie puisse montrer une nouvelle
vérité et contredire certaines stats
officielles dans certains pays et enfin
donc j'aurai trois grands points
le dernier point ça sera au niveau de
l'idéologie économique
alors comment expliquer ça donc moi
quand je dis je travaille
l'onction en thèse depuis 80 ans je
travaille sur le rôle d'internet et des
réseaux sociaux pour prévoir l'évolution
des cours boursiers
ce que je fais c'est du big data
appliquer la finance je fais des robots
qui vont extraire les informations sur
twitter sur les réseaux sociaux
lorsque vous allez les voir une page sur
wikipédia je le sais lorsque vous tapez
un truc sur google je le sais lorsque
vous mettez un message sur un forum de
discussion je le sais tout ça à partir
de ça donc comme si vous avez l'image de
big brother is watching you il ya aussi
des petits doctorants qui juste avec un
ordinateur chez eux vont extraire les
vos données et les uns et essayer de les
analyser
moi mon rôle c'est d'essayer de me dire
là les personnes pensent ça à propos
d'une entreprise il ya une forte
attention et derrière j'essaye de faire
des algorithmes de trading pour prévoir
l'évolution des cours financiers en
dehors de ça donc là on se rapprocherait
du nouveau test de la réalité
en dehors de ça ce qui m'intéresse dans
l'aspect big data c'est le côté
idéologique
j'ai une petite anecdote relatif à une
conférence donc que j'ai fait il ya un
peu plus de six mois maintenant pour
montrer en fait la nouvelle vision de la
part des jeunes chercheurs ou en tout
cas
finalement la vision que j'ai moi et que
je partage avec pas mal d'autres
doctorants pardon qui justement que
l'idéologie n'a pas sa place en économie
l'anecdote donc je présente mon papier à
une conférence de recherche en face de
plein de chercheurs à la fin il ya un
chercheur plus âgés qui me pose une
question mais il me fait votre
conférence très bien de la barre et
ensuite une pose la question mais en
fait vous personnellement
est ce que vous croyez plus en la tva ou
est ce que vous croyez plus en la
théorie b en l'occurrence pour ceux qui
connaissent efficience des marchés ou
finance comportementale
ma réponse qui lui a pas forcément plus
mais qui est la réponse qui a porté par
plein de jeunes chercheurs face à ce
type de question c'est de dire moi je
fais de la recherche empirique mon avis
n'a rien à voir dans ma recherche
j'ai pas d'idéologie je prends des
données je teste je conclus tout ça pour
dire qu'en fait le big data peut
permettre justement de supprimer en
partie l'idéologie et de retourner à une
certaine vérité des données pourquoi
auparavant lorsqu'il ya peu de données
quelqu'un pense quelque chose quelqu'un
ponte quelque chose d'autre dans ce cas
là vous vous combattez à base idéologie
à partir du moment où vous avez des
données et surtout quand vous avez des
millions et des millions de données
il ya une sorte de pas forcément une
vérité unique est en tout cas les
données peuvent parler pour confirmer ou
infirmer dans certains cas des théories
il ya une phrase que j'aime beaucoup qui
est une phrase de gary king donc dans un
article publié en 2011 qui dit ce qui se
passe actuellement aux sciences sociales
c'est vrai en économie mais c'est vrai
finalement dans toutes les sciences
sociales
c'est que et qu'on parle justement en
disant ce qu'on voit actuellement c'est
exactement la même chose que ce qui
s'est passé avec l'appareil
l'apparition pardon du microscope en
microbiologie
l'idée c'est que maintenant vous pouvez
finalement analysé traquer des
phénomènes micro économiques qui étaient
impossibles à analyser avant donc tout
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle la révolution
au big data en économie et en finance
attention cependant petites choses je
vous présente les côtés positifs il ya
quand même pas mal d'aspects négatifs
dès qu'on parle des big data forcément
vous avez toujours les mêmes problèmes
de protection de
des données privées vous avez toujours
les mêmes problèmes du fait que les
entre les données sont contrôlées par
des entreprises privées ce qui peut
mettre un peu à mal l'indépendance de la
recherche et en plus qui dit plus de
données dit plus de facilité à prouver
ce qu'on veut avec les données
manipulation donné c'est très simple
personnellement moi sur ma tête j'ai
plusieurs dizaines de millions de
données à partir de cela vous pouvez
finalement arriver à prouver à peu près
n'importe quoi pour finir sur une petite
note positive quand même on a vu donc au
tout début la phrase de l'entière la
phrase de krugman dans ces deux phrases
léontieff krugman critiquer avec 30 ans
d'écart le fait que l'économie
mathématique purement théorique ne
permet pas ne permettait pas de répondre
aux questions présentes et finalement
été déconnectés de la réalité
ce que j'ai envie de faire là avec vous
ce soir j'ai envie de prendre le pari
que dans 15 ans futur ni de prix nobel
qui au passage d'ailleurs ce sera
sûrement renaissance man
on voit de plus en plus d'économistes
qui sont moitié économistes moitié
financier moitié sociologue moitié geek
donc on instaure de renaissance man de
l'économie qui arrivent et je suis prêt
à prendre le pari avec vous que ce futur
prix nobel d'économie renaissance man de
l'économie dans 15 ans ou 20 ans
lorsqu'il parlera de l'état de la
science économique
son regard sera pas c'est purement
théorique mathématiques ça ne marche pas
mais justement dire que grâce au big
data grâce au mélange des compétences et
à l'ouverture de l'économie
maintenant on a réussi à reconnecter
l'économie de la réalité adam 15 ans